this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up guys michael here today we're
going to talk about what will likely be
the most important film this year to
feature sentient rocks no we don't mean
dwayne we're talking about everything
everywhere all at once or as we like to
call it michelle yo and the multiverse
of sadness this isn't the first movie to
use the multiverse as a storytelling
device but while some of these other
films might be accused of i don't know
using the multiverse as a way to
backdoor corporate ip into increasingly
flimsy narratives everything everywhere
all at once is different it uses the
multiverse to say some genuinely
interesting things about everything from
24 7 digital culture to how sometimes
parents just don't understand one of the
film's directors even said it explores
his own adult adhd diagnosis and its
effects on his life but what really
stood out to us is the way the film
explores two of our favorite
philosophical sensibilities
existentialism and nihilism and while
we've talked about these two spicy
meatballs or hot dog fingers before
everything everywhere all at once does
something super interesting in using the
multiverse to explore the metaphysical
implications of the aforementioned
meatballs so does this film use the
multiverse to show us a way out of
existential despair or should we all be
praying for nihilist bagels to put us
out of our misery let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on everything
everywhere all at once does anything
mean anything anywhere and of course
major spoilers ahead for the movie
but before we dive in i want to tell you
about this week's sponsor surfsharkvpn
surfsharkvpn keeps your data secure with
cutting-edge vpn protocols and
uncrackable encryption now one of my
favorite things about surfshark is the
way it keeps my location totally private
and when websites can't figure out where
in the world i'm located that means they
can't hike up prices for things like
plane tickets just based on how much
they think i can afford instead i can
connect my secure surfsharkvpn to vpns
in different countries until i score a
good deal and the same logic applies to
watching streaming movies and tv shows
too with a securevpn it doesn't matter
if the movie or show i want to see has
been released in the us yet instead i
can join an international vpn to get
that sweet sweet content one
subscription covers all of your favorite
devices like your laptop android amazon
fire stick playstation and more plus you
can still use your favorite apps like
firefox and chrome get started by
clicking the link in the description and
using the promo code wisecrack when you
do you can get surfshark dpn for 83 off
plus three extra months for free go to
surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show let's start with the film's
central characters the wang family
you've got serious and stressed evelyn
her goofy but good-hearted husband
waymond and their angsty daughter joy
each of these characters is going
through their own type of existential
crisis right off the bat and that's
before the fabric of reality starts to
unravel evelyn embodies a type of
mundane existential despair as she's
seemingly depressed at the state of her
life and keenly aware of what she hasn't
accomplished she very much has the vibes
of a character from a sart or camus
novel we even learn that she's the only
evelyn in the multiverse who never
excelled at anything with every passing
moment you feel you might have missed
your chance to make something of your
life and during an irs meeting we see
that she hasn't let go of various failed
dreams you're also a novelist
and a chef last time you told me
please and then we have joy when we
first meet her she's feeling alienated
from her mother both interpersonally and
also at the level of wanting her
queerness to be recognized
oh
but later on we'll know her as jobu
topaki once her mind is shattered and
exist in every iteration of the
multiverse while the original joy is
just looking for meaning in her everyday
life jobu topaki is on a search for
meaning at the cosmic level existing in
every multiverse has left her convinced
everything is random nothing means
anything and there is no truth and
finally we have weymond but first
doesn't appear to suffer as deeply as
his wife and daughter but he does seem
dejected by the loss of love in his
marriage rather than seeking some type
of cosmic meaning or purpose this dude
just wants to love and be loved so to
really get to the bottom of what these
characters are going through we need to
revisit our old friends existentialism
and nihilism now we've covered these
topics in the past and if you need a
primer check out our classic video on
rick and morty and bojack
written by yours truly but something we
haven't talked about before is what the
early existentialists were responding to
namely rationalist and idealist schools
of thought that believed the structure
of reality was something that was
knowable through human consciousness i.e
that we can make sense of everything
which is what philosophers call
metaphysics the two most notable
proto-existentialists nietzsche and
kierkegaard came right after the era of
german idealism during which a crew of
philosophers tried to figure out the
nature of the absolute put differently
they were trying to logically comprehend
everything everywhere all at once corny
sure but an apt description of what
philosophers like hegel and victor were
doing absolutely and these idealist
philosophers offered an account of both
how human consciousness works but also
how the reality outside of our
consciousness functions in their minds
they had more or less reached the final
boss of philosophy but for some of the
folks that came in their wake the idea
that individual human minds could
somehow comprehend all the features of
reality was a humorous illusion at best
they weren't ready to go full to pocky
and even those who thought these
absolute idealists were onto something
still thought that this level of
rational understanding wasn't making
folks any less miserable we see
parallels in the film's antagonist joe
butupaki jobu is able to experience
everything that's happening at all times
but instead of giving her some greater
sense of truth or meaning it's made her
absolutely miserable turning her into a
nihilist with a penchant for
experimental fashion and creative
murders and this makes us think about a
fellow traveler of the existentialist
albert camus what his friends jean-paul
simona maurice described as the
existential condition he called the
absurd the absurd describes what happens
when there is a contradiction between
two ideals for example humanity's desire
for meaning and purpose and the
universe's seemingly cold and
meaningless structure not to get too
trippy but it's basically what happens
if you're sitting underneath the stars
with someone you love that feeling of
love seems super meaningful when you're
gazing at your beloved but when you turn
and stare up at the seemingly lifeless
infinity of our universe it's hard to
not wonder if human meaning is just a
pleasant delusion we all share or if
you're joe butaki the absurd is the
contradiction between thinking that your
individual life has some sort of meaning
and then experiencing the seeming
randomness and meaninglessness of life
across the multiverse for evelyn it
could be the contradiction between her
mundane and unfulfilling life and seeing
that in another timeline she's a movie
star now this contradiction drives jobu
to bagel-centered nihilism which we'll
get back to in a second but that wasn't
camus journey he thought that the
individual could face the absurd in
three ways
suicide and to be clear he did not
endorse this and there is no reading of
the existentialist tradition that
endorses ending your own life a leap of
faith in which you turn to religion for
meaning or a type of recognition or
rebellion in which you acknowledge the
utter absurdity of existence but are
still able to discover meaning at the
individual level it's sort of embracing
the paradox that while the universe
might have no inherent meaning you're
going to keep searching for some meaning
nonetheless it's kind of like searching
for your soulmate at a funeral in this
way camus absurdism is neither as
cosmically hopeless as nihilism nor is
positive in its embrace of freedom and
humanity as existentialism at a certain
point in the movie it seems like jobu
and evelyn have chosen camus very dark
first option as jobu's despair makes her
want to simply be sucked into the empty
void of the bagel rather than face the
absurdity of their situation they'd
prefer not to exist at all because as we
see during evelyn's laundromat rampage
what's the point for some contemporary
theorists camus solution is kind of a
cop-out he comes close to embracing
absolute cosmic meaninglessness but he
doesn't go all the way one such theorist
is writer eugene thacker who in his
aptly titled in the dust of this planet
argues that there might not be a purpose
to think or to your life or to your
existence or to the cosmos that there
might not be an order that we're not
here for a reason that it's arbitrary
and an accident for thacker this cosmic
nihilism leads to a philosophy of
pessimism which takes a largely negative
view of life and existence pessimists
believe that the conditions of existence
often make life pretty shitty for most
people most of the time
this seems to be the vibe of jobu's crew
of circle-headed weirdos because life is
anyways they embrace being sucked into
the hole of a heavily seasoned bagel
philosopher ray brossier takes this
pessimistic view even further in his
understanding of our desire for meaning
as he sees it because we can be
scientifically certain that eventually
the sun is going to die out and explode
there will be an inevitable heat death
to the universe and earth will be
cosmically cancelled in this process all
human consciousness and history and
thought and art and everything else is
going to be destroyed forever and
rendered cosmically meaningless and in
light of this cosmic bummer we need to
reconsider our desire for meaning and
maybe reconsider the idea that real
meaning is something that we can ever
find in the first place
basically if the bagel is eventually
going to suck it all into oblivion
anyways none of what's happening now
really matters all that much does it
classic existentialism absurdism and
nihilism are all about what we should do
practically and ethically if life is
meaningless but there are contemporary
philosophers who have functionally
turned existentialism back into a kind
of metaphysics remember the very thing
existentialism developed in opposition
to basically if existentialism was more
about how we should live
metaphysics consists of classic
questions about the meaning of reality
now the metaphysical implications of
thinkers like dacker and brassiere would
of course be ideal reading for jobu and
the bagel gang's book group they
basically confirm jobu's nihilistic
metaphysics by arguing that the cosmos
is a cold uncaring nothing and that life
is mostly pain and despair with a few
little moments of happiness sprinkled
here and there and like we already said
at a certain point it seems like evelyn
wants in on the book group as well but
she snaps out of it due to weymouth's
simple but effective plea for everyone
to just be kind the only thing i do know
is that we have to be kind
and while this could strike some as
corny and reductive as if being kind is
a cure to large scale metaphysical
meaninglessness that actually gets at
something important now for thacker and
brassiere pessimism and nihilism aren't
just existential principles but
metaphysical and even scientific ones
because when everything humanity has
ever created is burned like a bagel left
in the toaster too long
nothing we will have ever done is really
gonna matter and all attempts to find
happiness and purpose in the meantime
are equivalent to closing your eyes and
listening to a mildly interesting
podcast as your plane hurtles towards
the ground but this of course isn't
where the wang family ends up evelyn
inspired by waymon's unceasing optimism
and calls for kindness in the face of
fear decides that existence is something
worth fighting for and rather than using
her homicidal pinkies to take out her
enemies she responds with a love and
kindness that seems to target the fear
and despair motivating her opponents and
maybe not surprisingly some recent
french philosophers the children and
grandchildren of the existentialist so
to speak are using the spirit of
existentialism to combat the metaphysics
of nihilist despair okay so it's like
this the existentialist operated with
the principle that the true nature of
reality was basically unknowable and
trying to understand it would just make
us miserable because we'd always
experience the contradiction between our
subjectivity and the objective nature of
reality instead we should focus on
making decisions and taking
responsibility for our own existence and
anyways why worry about metaphysics when
you can drink martinis but contemporary
philosophers like alon beju and quentin
miyazu are both continuing to embrace
the power that decisions play in
existence while also embracing
metaphysics and well it's kind of a lot
of complicated stuff the gist is that
while the ex-essential is focused on the
inconsistency between reality and our
attempts to understand it this newer
crop of french smarties identify that
inconsistency as a feature of reality
itself in one sense it seems like there
is a lack of freedom in the everything
everywhere all at once multiverse as
each version of evelyn seems borderline
destined to carry out a specific type of
existence but baju would argue that
while each of these universes seems to
have finite limits within each universe
there is a trans-finite sense of
possibility put simply while we would
normally consider the distance between
the numbers 1 and 2 to be a finite limit
within that limit there is an infinite
amount of numbers i.e 1.0 1.34 1.5
nine 1.000 o four three five six
etcetera in existential terms this means
that even if we're caught in a certain
finite condition i.e we have hot dogs
for fingers we still have infinite
possibilities within those conditions
i.e we can learn to play the piano with
our feet for baju this means that novel
things can happen in seemingly finite
situations and when these things happen
under what he calls the four conditions
of truth art love science and politics
we're capable of finding ideas that can
give our lives meaning and these ideas
share something with existentialism and
that we can't simply believe in them
like they're true or false rather we
need to take responsibility for the
consequences of these ideas in our own
lives at the end of the film evelyn and
joy's futures aren't certain just
because they've decided to avoid
annihilation by bagel they'll have to
stay faithful to their decision each day
as they continue to find meaning in
their lives and miyazu argues that
rather than reality being either a
chaotic meaningless mess or a
well-ordered system of necessary truth
and causation it is both contingent and
necessary or as he puts it the only
necessity is contingency to put it in
terms a raccoon chef could understand
it's not that reality doesn't make sense
because we're not capable of
understanding it it's that reality
simply doesn't make sense in a clearly
logical way it's basically a metaphysics
reverse engineered out of existentialism
and this view of reality seems to be
there in the scene in the movie that
really made me cry a lot here all we get
are a few
specks of time where any of this
actually makes any sense
here evelyn and jobu are able to
acknowledge that reality doesn't make
sense and at the same time there is
space for them to create their own
meaning and purpose
then i will cherish
these few specks of time and everything
everywhere all at once seems to be
saying precisely this that even though
the universe doesn't have any inherent
sense of order or meaning that within
the context of these seemingly random
contingencies we are capable of creating
meaning and when we get scared or feel
stupid because reality and existence
don't make sense to us problem isn't us
it's that reality itself is kind of a
mess so does everything everywhere all
at once end up confirming that the
universe is inherently meaningful and
that if we just look hard enough meaning
and truth will be right there waiting
for us absolutely not but the film isn't
coldly embracing nihilism instead it
seems to be taking the route of arguing
that just because reality doesn't come
pre-loaded with meaning doesn't mean
that we can't create truth in our own
lives but what do you all think is
everything everywhere all at once a
necessary tonic for a time when reality
feels pretty warped to begin with or
were you just wondering when the
superheroes were going to show up let us
know in the comments thanks to our
patrons for all your support and don't
forget to check out our new perks on
patreon and also check out our new
stream wisecrack live right here
thursdays 11am pacific time press that
subscribe button like you're sticking a
googly eye to your forehead and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
so
[Music]